[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof
welcome back walter oh welcome back to
you too
so how have you been this past week
um would you like a long list of
ailments or shall we just carry on with
the program let's carry on with the
problem
and we'll just carry on i'll open up
with the word of prayer
our only father thank you for bringing
us together again
we ask again that you bless the
discussion and that you also open our
minds with the
working of the holy spirit in jesus name
amen
we've been working from the last episode
we want to get
to persecution climax
what's the issue what's what's on the
horizon
and today we're going to talk again
about the sabbath
people must be sick and tired of the
sabbath right yeah
that's the first question why again with
the sabbath what
are you going on about it the whole time
well it seems to be like a trademark
right
so why is it important are we going to
talk about
the details of the sabbath no we've done
that before
we're going to talk about the role of
the sabbath and the end times
that's what we're going to talk about
yes that's
it's because it plays a
very prominent role perhaps you can't
get rid of it you can't get rid of it
so yeah we have to talk about it again
and then we're also going to see
what some other people are saying about
the sabbath
that's the interesting bit so
sabbath or not is one of the questions
and the other one is
children of israel or children of god
where do you get that from
well i've heard some people say that
the old testament talks about the
children of israel
but we're not the children of israel
anymore okay
we're now the children of god so they
actually
put it the old testament and the new
testament now what about adam who was
son of god
if you read the genealogy then it says
begat so-and-so begat so-and-so adam son
of god.
so originally when adam was created he
was the son of god
and then
let's start talking about the children
of israel
now who was israel it was jacob right
and when did jacob become israel after
he's wrestling with the lord
after he wrestles with the lord what was
he wrestling about
to be blessed ah he wanted to be blessed
and he would not let
go because his sins overwhelmed him
and he would not let go until the lord
blessed him
and so his name was changed to israel
and thereafter the descendants of jacob
were called the children of israel
so basically israel means wrestled with
god
right and overcame so everybody who
wrestles with god
and overcomes in other words finds
forgiveness in christ and is covered by
christ's righteousness
becomes the israel of god
now in today's world you have a little
literal
israel which is an interesting name in
the past you had the northern tribes
which were called israel and the other
ones were called
judah but they were all the children of
israel
so there were both houses were the
children of israel
so we have to look at this issue and are
the children of israel not the children
of god
or are they implicitly the children of
god yeah or is there
separation is there difference exactly
so let's look at some of these issues
does christ have two wives
well that's what dispensationalism
basically teaches he has two brides
so you have a literal israel and you
have a church
isaiah 2 19 and i will betroth thee
unto me forever yeah will betroth thee
unto me in righteousness and
in judgment and in loving kindness and
in mercies
and second corinthians we jump to the
new testament it says for i am jealous
of
you with a godly jealousy for i have
espoused you to
one husband that i may present you as a
chaste
virgin to christ so the one is talking
about
the children of israel and the other one
is talking to the church
and they both have the same husband
where do you get your righteousness from
from christ are you sure yes is there
any other place where you can get it
no way no that's the only place that you
can get it right
uh who who has
who is the the the one over all judgment
also oh it's christ
so where do we find mercy also in christ
so the god of the old testament the god
of the new testament
one and the same we're talking about
jesus christ
and the whole bible is about jesus
christ yes
in acts 13 verse 32 we read and we
declare
unto you glad tidings how that the
promise which was made
unto the fathers who's he talking about
the
israelites the children of israel
god has fulfilled the same unto us
their children in that he has raised up
jesus again
as it is also written in the second
psalm thou art my son this day i have
begotten thee
so the promises for israel apply to whom
to everyone give everyone to the church
as well right
galatians 3 29 and if ye be christ's
then ye be abraham's seed
and heirs according to the promise
that's interesting that's putting it so
abraham's seed that's the children of
israel right
and he's talking here to the new
testament people or the old testament
new testament
so if you be christ then ye be abraham's
seed
not the other way around so when it
talks about
abraham's seed it's singular
that's christ paul makes that very clear
in in the new testament right
so if you are in christ then you are the
seed of abraham
because only in christ do you find
salvation
so we're not talking about a literal
seed
well we are talking about a literal seed
that seed being christ
but in terms of who the promises apply
to everyone who is in christ everyone
who followed the cloud
everybody who looked at the pole with
the serpent the symbol of christ who
became sin
for us by faith
shall be saved so it's about christ
to separate them is a misnomer
you shall not separate what christ has
brought together
can i ask what about now the
different covenants is there different
covenants
is there some that were made only with
israel and then others with the
new testament people well what is the
new covenant the new covenant
is that the law is written in your
hearts so the law is not done away with
absolutely not it was written on stone
and hopefully they had it in their heart
but the new covenant is with those who
have it in their heart
it applies to those who are in christ in
other words that's all it says
so the old testament is the gospel in
type
the new testament is the gospel in
verity it's the same gospel
now galatians chapter 4 verse 28 says
now we
brethren as isaac was are the children
of promise
who is he speaking to the
the church yes they're speaking to the
church so
the church or the children of promise
so if you reject christ
are you then still the seed of of
abraham no no because only when you are
in christ
are you the seed of abraham galatians 6
15 for in christ jesus neither
circumcision availeth anything nor
uncircumcision but a new creature
what is this new creature one who has
accepted jesus christ as his personal
savior
one who has wrestled with christ and
found forgiveness through repentance
mercy righteousness in christ
and there wasn't a difference for the
old
testament israelites as well they also
the circumcision didn't
bring you to christ you had to be
that was just a sign you had to have it
was an
outside symbol of an inner conviction
galatians 6 16 and as many as walk
according to
this rule peace be on them and mercy
upon the israel of god so who's the
israel of god
those who are in christ yes
now let's go back in history and see
what eusebius's view was
now he was this historian remember
famous historian
and he wrote then the spiritual seed of
abraham
fled to pella so tell me
who fled topela was it the christians or
was it the jews
the christians ah so the spiritual
seed of abraham let's say the christians
fled to pella on the other side of the
jordan yeah this was with the
destruction of the
jerusalem correct what did they do there
where they found a safe place of refuge
and could serve their master and
excuse me what was that keeping the
sabbath
so who kept the sabbath the christians
that fled from jerusalem
that's according to eusebius now
dispensationalists
like to separate them into these two
groups the church
and literal israel and there are two
dispensations for each one of them
and then they still have the confusion
that the one will be raptured and the
other will
reign with christ the thousand years
down here
while the poor thousand-year-old widow
waits up there now
where does that doctrine come from is it
in the bible no
no so it comes out of the pen of the
jesuits right correct
it is incomprehensible to me that
protestants
should follow the dictates of jesuitical
teaching but that's a fact that's how it
works
so now here's a quote from patriarchs
and prophets
in eden god set up the memorial of his
work of creation in placing his blessing
upon the seventh
day there's no doubt about that and god
bless the sabbath day it says in genesis
chapter 2
the sabbath was committed to adam
the father and representative of the
whole human family
so we start off with the sabbath correct
okay let me ask you two trick questions
here they're not trick questions they're
straightforward
are the ten commandments mentioned in
genesis chapter 1.
no is the sabbath man
mentioned in genesis chapter 2 yes at
the culmination of genesis chapter 1
right
right at the beginning of chapter 2 yes
so
the sabbath was prominent from the
beginning
we assumed that obedience was part of
the deal
because they had to make a choice
between good and evil
and what is evil what is iniquity
iniquity is transgression of the law yes
okay so adam must have
verbally received instructions from god
and the sabbath
is pertinently mentioned correct so he's
the father and the representative of the
whole human family
so the whole human family got the
sabbath
was there a jew then no was there
were there children of israel no because
jacob hadn't
lived yet right he was still as it were
corporately in adam he wasn't there yet
so its observance was to be an act of
grateful acknowledgement on the part
of all who should dwell upon the earth
that god was their creator
and their rightful sovereign so it was a
sign from the beginning
yes that they were the work of his hands
and the subjects of
his authority i mean you can't put it
better than this this is
spot on thus the institution was holy
commemorative and given to all
mankind there was nothing in it shadowy
or of restricted application to any
people
there was no sin yet yes it was a
permanent institution given to humanity
the sabbath was made
for man and given to humanity
god designs that the sabbath shall
direct the minds of
men to the contemplation of his created
works
nature speaks to their senses declaring
that there is a living god the creator
the supreme
ruler of all and then there's a quote
from
psalms the heavens declare the glory of
god and the firmament showeth his
handiwork
day unto day utterance speech and night
unto night showeth
knowledge the beauty that closed the
earth is a token of god's love we may
behold it
in the everlasting hills and the lofty
trees and the opening buds and the
delicate flowers
all speak to us of god the sabbath ever
pointed to him
who made them all bids men opened the
great book of nature and traced there in
the wisdom the power and the love of the
creator
there's nobody who doesn't love nature
even the pope loves nature
it seems he has no encyclical on him
but who's the god of nature do we
worship the
things or do we worship the god of the
things
that is the question the sabbath was
instituted in the previous episode you
mentioned
the original will of god in the
permissive world
with his original woe the sabbath was
instituted it was there already yes
so now let's ask the question
why do christian denominations today
not recognize the sabbath
now we've done many lectures in the past
on the sabbath it's not our aim to
discuss
the sabbath in those details you can put
links in
yes i put links of the lectures and
sermons
that's been done on the sabbath and then
people can compare it for themselves
to what is being said by the
denominations
now humanity is basically in rebellion
right and the sabbath
is a very pivotal part of all of this
now here's a quote from various well
let's go to various
protestant ministries today to find out
why they don't keep the sabbath yes and
we are working towards
a goal here yes so absolutely
so let's look at kenneth copeland
ministries this is his web
page and he asks the question here why
do christians worship on sunday
instead of on the sabbath
a sabbath means rest
the first reference we find in the bible
about taking a sabbath rest is god's
command in exodus 16 23
26 well it's not quite right
the first reference we find to rest is
god rested on the sabbath
day and that was genesis chapter 2 right
but let's leave it at that but anyway
exodus chapter 16
is not where the law was given that was
before
the law was given in genesis in exodus
chapter 20.
he told them this is what the lord
commanded tomorrow will be a day of
complete rest the holy sabbath day
set apart for the lord
observance of the sabbath day was a part
of the law given
exclusively to israel
is that true no we'll find out
it was included in their covenant with
god which provided their redemption
under the law the people of israel were
commanded not to do
work of any kind on the seventh day of
the week
saturday well at least he knows that
to take a physical rest and to worship
god
exodus 20 8-11 that's the sabbath
commandment
this day served as a reminder that god
created the earth in six days and rested
on the seventh
that he delivered israel from the
bondage of
egypt and he's quoting deuteronomy and
genesis
and that his promised messiah would
bring the true rest of
redemption okay
so he's got some things right there and
some things
not quite right
some question whether having church
services on sunday
violates god's law they wonder where the
tradition of
sunday church services originated well
he's got that right
it's a tradition from scripture we learn
that there was not a law for what day
believers were to worship
galatians 4 9 to 11 colossians 2
16. this is fascinating we'll have to
look at that
we know the disciples frequently met on
sunday
acts 27
1 corinthians 16 2 revelation 1
10 the lord's day that is fascinating
does it say the lord's day is sunday in
revelation
no no it doesn't say that in fact if you
go through your entire bible there's
only
one definition of what is the lord's day
and that is in isaiah chapter 58 you
shall
keep the sabbath and the lord's day
honorable
so this is what we call
babylonian confusion
it comes from the mind of an apostate
church
some have suggested it is possible
believers began meeting on sunday
in honor of the lord's resurrection
others point to it later becoming
official when christianity became the
official religion of the omen
roman empire under constantine but
no new command dictated that day he's
got that right
isn't that interesting okay
so why are they keeping sunday
he says there's no commandment so it's a
tradition
and well the early church
sometimes we're together on a sunday and
we'll look at those texts as well
as we carry on the important thing to
remember is that jesus came to redeem us
from the law of sin
and death so we could have true
spiritual rest and fellowship with god
not just one day a week but every day
not through what we do but through what
he did on the cross to provide for our
right standing
with god then he quotes romans and
ephesians
as christians we can gather together at
any day time or place and jesus said he
would be right there
with us that's perfectly true does that
negate the sabbath there
no no
so in other words what he's saying we
meet on sunday but it doesn't matter we
could meet on any day
correct but sunday seems to be very
important to them
so basically they've made a new law
which is not in the bible no new command
dictated that day
so that's one view now here's another
view
this is interesting this is rick warren
and we would like to know what his view
on the sabbath is right
correct so let's listen to what he has
to say and then we'll
talk about it why are we doing this
to show the people what the
denominations out there are actually are
actually saying
and then what's coming in the future
why is it important yes what are the
denominations saying
and are they all on the same page in
this issue exactly
or are they on different pages only
thing that they have the same is the day
although they say it's not important
then why make a big deal of it if it's
not important exactly
why make a big deal if you keep the
sabbath exactly
i remember many times many years ago a
lady said to me said you know
pastor i i tried to call you all day
monday
and i said well i'm sorry but monday is
it's my day off it's my sabbath
and she said well the devil never takes
a day off
i said yeah and if i didn't i'd be just
like the devil
god rest god rest are you busier than
god
the bible tells us this on the screen
exodus 31 verse 17
one day a week god says will always
serve as a reminder
that i made the heavens and the earth in
six days and then
on the seventh day i rested and relaxed
now why did god rest and relax on the
seventh day
well he certainly wasn't tired because
god doesn't get tired
and god never gets stuck but he was
modeling for us
what he wanted us to do to rest
and to relax to keep a sabbath to have
balance
and to relax in in the goodness
this is an important one limit my work
to six days a week you say
you're kidding me i'm saying if you're
not doing that
you're breaking one of god's big ten the
ten commandments
rest and recreation are so important to
life
god put it in the big ten the ten
commandments right up there with
don't commit adultery don't murder and
don't steal he says every six days you
take a day off
if you're not taking a day off every
week
you are breaking the ten commandments
he said well i'd never murder anybody
i'd never commit adultery but are you
taking a day off every week
it's right up there with in the big ten
that's how important god considers
rest and recreation and relaxation
now this is the fourth commandment and
when god gives a commandment he's
serious about it this is not like an
option like
well if you feel like it take a day off
no it's called the sabbath let me show
you some verses
exodus 23 12 here on the screen work
the first six days of the week but rest
and relax
on the seventh this is the law
he says this law is not only for you
but all for also for your animals so
your pet needs to have a sabbath
as well as everyone else including
foreigners among you
god says i don't want anybody
unprotected
from this law he said this law of
rest and recreation and having the
sabbath having a day off every week
said everybody should be protected from
overwork including
immigrants and foreigners who have come
in
they shouldn't be overworking either now
here's the fourth commandment
exodus 20 verse 9 and 10. this is one of
the 10 commandments fourth commandment
you have six days in which to do your
work
but the seventh day is to be a day of
complete
rest circle that complete rest dedicated
to me now this is called
the sabbath every seventh day you take a
day off
and a sabbath you might write this down
sabbath means a day of rest
that's what it means and you know did
you know that your heart
actually beats different different every
seven days
we're biologically wired for a day of
rest
now this whole idea of where god says
once you have a day of rest and worship
it's not for god's benefit
it's not just some arbitrary law god did
it so you won't burn out
and the reason people are so stressed
out today is they've forgotten this
in culture after culture after culture
after culture it's for
your benefit look at this mark 2 verse
27 jesus said
the sabbath was made to benefit
men in other words god didn't make the
sabbath for his benefit he made it for
ours
when i ignore god's laws who gets hurt
not god
i get hurt when i don't follow the
owner's manual now
when is your sabbath i'm telling you it
doesn't matter what day of the week
you take your sabbath the bible says
this many times in the new testament
what day you worship on what day you
take as your day off as your day of rest
your day of recreation
it doesn't matter the day you just need
to do it every week
okay my sabbath is not saturday my
sabbath is not sunday i'm working on
those days
my sabbath is every monday it's monday
and by the way i would encourage you to
not call it your day off because if you
call it your day off you'll cheat on it
you need to start calling your day off
your sabbath
now that was the most fascinating
discourse
and i think we could talk for hours on
it
but let's just mention a few salient
points
he says a sabbath the bible says
the sabbath he says
any day the bible says
the seventh day but the seventh day
is the sabbath of the lord your god on
it you shall do no work neither you nor
your ox nor your donkey
in other words your tractor stays in the
barn
that's what it's about unless you're
going to do an
act of mercy right so
it's fascinating to me that he says this
law is binding
yes absolutely binding it's part of the
big ten
you have to keep it and you're breaking
god's ten commandments if you don't keep
a sabbath but he consistently talks
about
his sabbath now many people have told me
oh you keep your sabbath and i'll keep
my sabbath so i've had this argument
many times and i
i try to correct them i say no no no you
keep your sabbath and i'll keep
god's sabbath because god said
the seventh day now who's lord of the
sabbath
jesus jesus is lord of the sabbath
did jesus keep the sabbath day yes
but according to his principles
very well so here we have a very
interesting statement
he says it's part of the law of god it's
part of the big
term it's obligatory you have to keep
it but you can choose any day you like
it's not biblical it never says so in
the bible
he says it's written many times in the
new testament we'll look at that he's
misquoting the bible
he's totally ignoring the precept
right that's great so interesting so
file that
um copeland also said basically any day
yes that's part of the commandment same
and
he also said there's no new commandment
that says it has to be on the sunday
that's correct so both of them are
way off when it comes to what the
scripture says
now rick warren said many times in the
new testament
and copeland also said they came
together on the first day of the week
yeah so let's have a look at those texts
it's interesting that those texts are
mentioned
eight times and this is a main argument
that these
were there to show you that we should
worship on a sunday
so the resurrection was was a
major event in history i mean it is the
event of history and it took place on
the first day of the week
nowhere does it say we must commemorate
that day
by keeping it as a rest day right
so let's look at the text the first one
we find in matthew 28 verse 1 and in the
end of the sabbath as it began to dawn
towards the first day of the week okay
mary magdalene
and other mer the other mary to see the
sepulcher
the new english bible says the sabbath
had passed and it was about daybreak on
sunday
so does this say that they worshipped on
that day
or that the day has been changed no not
at all
so it doesn't say anything of that
nature so it's just a statement of fact
he rose on the first day of the week
good let's just look at this here
it says here in luke 23 54-56
and that day was the preparation
that's when he was crucified and the
sabbath drew near
and the women also which came with him
from galilee followed after
and beheld the sepulcher and how his
body was laid
and they returned and prepared spices
and ointment and rested the sabbath day
according to the commandment so it's
very clear
that the commandment was still in place
and kept when jesus died
yes so the previous verse where it
mentioned the first day of the week was
just
telling us that they went to the grave
on the first day of the week
yes now here's the second verse that
mentions the first day of the week and
that's mark 16 1 and 2
and when the sabbath was passed again
you know exactly
the seventh day is the sabbath mary
magdalene and mary the mother of james
and salome
had bought sweet spices they might come
anoint him
and very early in the morning the first
day of the week they came
unto the sepulcher at the rising of
the sun is there anything there that
they worshipped on the first day of the
week
no no nothing that the sabbath was
changed now to this first day
what did they kept as the sabbath on the
saturday the saturday the seventh day
right
so there's nothing there that the
sabbath was changed no
here's the third text mark 16 verse 9.
now when jesus was risen early the first
day of the week
he appeared first to mary magdalene out
of whom he had cast seven devils
are they worshiping on this day no no
they just came together on the first day
of the week right
okay so that's three down
here's the fourth one luke 24 verse one
now upon the first day of the week very
early in the morning they came under the
sepulcher bringing the spices which they
had prepared
and certain others with them anything
there no
nothing so we're whittling down
rick warren's verses right
we're on the fourth one okay
what about the fifth one this is john 20
verse 1. the first day of the week
cometh mary magdalene early when it was
yet dark
unto the sepulcher and see is the stone
taken away from the sepulcher
so the first five verses
just tell us that jesus rose on the
first day of the week and that the tomb
was empty right yes
that's it nothing else
the sixth verse then the same day at
evening being the first day of the week
when the doors were shut where the
disciples were assembled for fear of the
jews
came jesus and stood in their midst and
says unto them peace be unto you
this is the resurrection day yes so now
this is where the disciples got together
so the disciples got together to come
and celebrate and worship on the new
day that had been implemented by nobody
at all
because this is the first time jesus
appears to them
no they were there because they're
scared
aha so on the same day
and evening being the first day of the
week
in other words before sunset on the
first day of the week
when the doors were shut where the
disciples were assembled
not to worship but because they were
afraid of the jews
they felt pretty safe on the sabbath
they knew the jews wouldn't do anything
on the sabbath day
but on the first day they said whoops
what's going to happen now
so they got together and they were
scared and jesus appeared in the midst
of them and did he tell them at that
occasion
from now on you will keep the first day
of the week no no
even kenneth copeland says there's no
such command right
the seventh verse and upon the first day
of the week when the disciples came
together to break bread
oops they've got us yeah that's trouble
paul preached unto them ready to depart
on the
morrow and continued his speech
until midnight now
the new english bible says saturday
night
now this is interesting so
what happened here let's analyze this
verse they will say they came together
to break bread well the bible says they
came to break bread on a daily basis yes
so that wasn't the sabbath issue they
ate together they had a meal together
yes
so what happened here on the first day
of the week the disciples came together
for a meal to break bread and paul
preached in them
until midnight so when does this
when is the sabbath over this uh
yeah sunset saturday evening okay so
they kept the sabbath
and then after the sabbath they had a
church meeting yes
because it was evening oh he continued
preaching
into the night well they came together
and then he preached
until midnight but that was
yeah poor old uticus fell asleep
right fell out the window now why
was he preaching until midnight
because he was going to depart on the
morrow when the sun came up what day
would that be
the first day sunday paul was going to
go on a long journey
on the first day of the week wasn't he
keeping the new sabbath
obviously not right so they came
together on saturday night
after the sabbath so they'd kept the
sabbath
then they had a church meeting because
paul was going to leave the next morning
it wasn't sabbath to them
it was a work day he was on a mission
so he had a quick meeting with them
before
he departed so there's nothing there
about a new work
a new worship day and that's also not
changing the
now starting a new tradition absolutely
not let's really get a little bit more
details it says and there were many
lights in the upper chamber where they
were gathered together
so it was an evening meeting and it
wasn't sabbath anymore
no it was the first day of the week
when he therefore was come up again and
had broken bread and eaten
talked a long while even till break of
day
so he departed what day was that when he
departed first day
he didn't stay for worship
and they continuing daily with one
accord in the temple and breaking bread
from house to house did eat their meat
with gladness and singleness of heart
so there's no issue at all
that there was a worship service
dedicated to a new sabbath nothing of
the kind
and here's the last and final text
now concerning the collection for the
saints
as i have given order to the churches of
galatia
even so do ye upon the first day of the
week let every one of you
lay by him in store
the where myth translation says at his
home
as god has prospered him and there be no
gathering when i come
so now the people are saying oh they had
a church service and this is a church
collection
this verse is actually very interesting
now
in the old days and even in many places
still today
when was payday at the end of the week
what day the friday
fridays so friday you got your pay
now that would be towards the end of the
friday
right so paul is saying now concerning
the collection
for the saints as i've given orders to
the churches in galatia even so do
ye on the first day of the week
put your money aside that you want to
give to god
your tithe in other words so when did
they get their money
the friday why was he only going to put
it together on the first day of the week
they were keeping seven
ah they were keeping the sabbath and he
didn't want them
to go and count money and calculate what
goes to god what is offering what is
this
leave that for the first day of the week
and
when he comes he'll collect the did he
collect it on that day no
no they just put it aside and when he
came he would collect it
so is this first actually in favor of
the sabbath
as a rest day or the first time actually
yes okay so there are the eight verses
that's eight verses
mentioning the first day of the week and
all of them support the sabbath day
okay christ came to fulfill the law did
jesus
change the law this is the heading in
the king james bible
we didn't make that dating matthew 5
from verse 17 think not that i am come
to destroy the law
or the prophets i am not come to destroy
but to fulfill for verily i say unto you
till heaven and earth pass one jot or
one turtle shall in no
wise pass from the law till all be
fulfilled
are heaven and earth still here yes well
i think
i think so yeah exactly whosoever there
shall shall break one of the least
commandments of these commandments and
shall
teach men so he shall be called
the least in the kingdom of heaven so
now some people say
okay so it's all right to teach it you
just won't be very important in heaven
but that's not what it says we'll see
but whoever shall do and teach them the
same shall be called
great in the kingdom of heaven and then
he qualifies what's least
for i say unto you that except your
righteousness shall exceed the
righteousness of the scribes and
pharisees
you shall in no case enter into the
kingdom of heaven
a very important word exceed yes
not the same as now how can your
righteousness exceed
that of the scribes and the pharisees
the disciples were very surprised
because these were such holy people i
mean how can you be more holy than that
how can we be more holy the only way we
can be more holy
than anyone else that
assumes to be holy is by the imputed and
imparted righteousness of christ in
other words you have to accept christ
did he come to abolish the law
how long will it stand forever forever
will one jot or one tittle that's a
comma or a full stop
disappear out of the law so is the
fourth commandment still there
yes absolutely absolutely
so if you love me keep my commandments
he who says he loves me and keeps not my
commandments is a liar
and the truth is not in them and if you
teach others
that you don't have to keep the law or
you can keep any day
you must be careful because you're like
the scribes and the pharisees who make
their own laws
what did jesus say to them didn't he say
to them
you transgress the law of god
for your traditions
very important so we're keeping
traditions
in the world and not god's commandment
yes
because there's a they're saying that
even though it's not commanded the
tradition
it was the tradition of the disciples to
eventually
start keeping the sunday as a research
and that's
not a command of god you can't do that
exactly and now as we've seen
keeping tradition is putting you in
conflict with god
absolutely i am the lord i change not
i do not alter what has gone out of my
mouth
so the other verse of course that i
always mention is colossians 2
and they did not disappoint they threw
it in there
verse 16 and 17 let no man therefore
judge you in meat or in drink or in
respect of
an holy day of the new moon or
of the sabbath days plural
which are a shadow of things to come
but the body is of christ
so now let no one tell you what the
sabbath day is so rick warren says
his sabbath is mondays you can eat what
you like
you can do well where in the ten
commandments
does it say thou shalt not eat this that
or the other
nowhere does it say anywhere in the ten
commandments
what kind of meat offering or drink
offering you should bring
where does it say that in what law in
the
uh ceremonial laws aha
so when it talks about drink offerings
and meat offerings and
new moon days is it talking about
ceremonial days or
about sabbath day the ceremonial
how can you take that one the sabbath
here and put it separate and say that's
the ten commandments but the rest are
ceremonial and then by the way it's
plural
yeah unless of course you work with some
new translations which make it the
sabbath day which is a deliberate
falsehood snuck in there by an enemy of
god
right so the received text clearly tells
you
plural lowercase sabbath days
which means ceremonial sabbaths so the
ceremonial
sabbaths were a shadow of things to come
a shadow of what christ of christ
so the ceremonial sabbaths are gone not
the seventh-day sabbath
and maybe we can also mention here
there's a distinction between the
ceremonial sabbaths and all those laws
that was written
by the hand of moses in a book and was
put beside the ark
and not in the ark that was
the law written with the finger of god
that was in the ark and the ceremonial
law was against us
in other words it was against us because
it pointed to us
as sinners who needed redemption but the
law
told us what sin was so nowhere in the
new testament
is there a change of the law
now you and i we are seventh-day
adventists
are you a seventh-day adventist by
choice
yes you made a choice yes were you
coerced to become a seventh-day
adventist
no you know what
the very last thing that i would
logically become
[Music]
is the seventh-day adventist there must
be pretty
compelling reasons why you would keep
the seventh day holy
and believe that god
is your creator and redeemer in this
world
and that you're going to show it to the
world by honoring
his commandments right
so there are many many people
who argue against this issue we're
talking about some
big names today we had kenneth
copeland's view with rick warren's view
now this man over here
is kent oven and
i have a great respect for his his
thinking
and his his lectures and
all of these things so this is not an
attack on him
like we said this is not an attack on
any of these people
no no we showing this
to move towards a point we want to say
where does this theology come from and
how many permutations of this theology
are there out there
and each and every single one of them
stands in juxtaposition to the bible
the bible hasn't moved kenneth goblin
moved
rick warren moved let's see
whether kentucky has also moved let's
just listen to what he has to say
on the sabbath day
what about the sabbath well i get asked
probably every week i get books sent to
me i've got a whole section of our
library by probably every book ever
written by any seventh day adventist and
they're all trying to convert me over to
being a seventh adventist
and they send me all kinds of stuff and
don't send me anymore i've already got
them all okay i don't need any more
i've got lots of books all the books by
ellen g white eg white okay
who wrote and she was the prophetess of
the seventh adventist church i'm not
anti-seventh-day adventist i've
spoken at some of their churches and
there's a lot of good folks love the
lord genuinely saved going to heaven as
much as i am
but what is the truth about the sabbath
are we supposed to you know
work on the seven rest on the seventh
day is that the day of worship or the
day of rest or what is the truth about
the sabbath
well nehemiah chapter 9 it says thou
came us down upon mount sinai
and spaketh with them from heaven and
gave us them right judgments true laws
good statutes
and made us known unto them thy holy
sabbath
wait a minute this is nehemiah talking
about the time moses
received the sabbath from god that's
2500 years after the creation
see i don't have moses even on that
chart but 2500 years after the creation
god made the sabbath known to moses
you mean for 2500 years for more than a
third of human history
nobody kept this apparently so
he revealed it to moses he said in
exodus 16
see that the lord hath given you the
seventh day every man abide in his place
don't go out of your house on the
sabbath day well if that's really one of
the laws for the sabbath then you can't
have a seventh-day
church that meets someplace because
everybody's going out of their house to
get there
right you talk about a sabbath day's
journey in acts chapter one
jesus traveled on the sabbath okay
what's he doing out of his house
the bible says remember the sabbath and
it thou shalt not do any work don't you
do it nor your son nor your made servant
nor the stranger
not only can you not work you can't make
anybody else work which means if you
really want to honor and obey the
sabbath according to scripture
you cannot work and you can't make
anybody else work which means you cannot
use any utilities
because if you're using the city water
the city lights the city gas
you're making somebody work if you're
watching tv
you're making somebody work on the
sabbath if you go out to eat you're
making somebody work you can't do that
so he rested the seventh day the bible
says if they worked on the seventh day
exodus 31 they'd be put to death
so you've got to kill people that work
on the sabbath it's punishable by death
exodus 31 is a key passage on this the
lord said unto moses speak thou unto the
children of israel
saying my sabbaths ye shall keep
it is a sign between me and you the
children of israel shall keep the
sabbath i mean it's right there exodus
31 it's pretty clear
the sabbath was for the children of
israel i'm norwegian
sabbath god made some strange rules for
the children of israel because they were
to be a peculiar people
people were to look at them and say wow
that's strange what's different about
you guys and they were to be a testimony
to the world
but he didn't command all the world to
keep this he said the children of israel
shall keep the sabbath
that's what pretty clear in exodus 31
exodus 35 says you shall need kindle no
fire
which means you couldn't start your car
don't they run on internal combustion
you know you're starting a fire
so if you really want to keep the
sabbath you enjoy yourself i've never
met anybody
anybody who keeps the sabbath never met
one person okay
the elders of israel he said in ezekiel
28 he says i gave
them my sabbath to be a sign between me
and them
the sabbath is for the children of
israel again it tells us in ezekiel
chapter 20.
jesus was on the sabbath day going
through the corn he plucked the corn
because they were
hungry and they ate it first of all
what's he doing out of his house
and what's he doing working on the
sabbath day did he not keep it
the bible says in mark chapter 2 the
pharisees said why do you do that which
on the sabbath which is not lawful and
he said the sabbath was made for man not
man made for the sabbath
what's he doing out of his house and
what's he doing working on the sabbath
jesus said in mark 3 it's lawful to do
good on the sabbath day to save life
and they looked about they got angry at
him for his answer
and people today get angry at me because
i don't
keep what their idea of the sabbath is i
said look i keep
every day as holy i work seven days a
week for the lord
my whole life is soaked up into god's
work i do nothing else this is it
so people say do you you keep the
sabbath oh yeah and and monday and
tuesday and wednesday i keep them all
yeah keep them all okay
do them all jesus went outside on the
sabbath he took his disciples
with him what's he doing making them sin
he picked corn he healed people he got
angry at the hypocrites
he's not resting and being refreshed
that's for sure he's getting angry with
hypocrites on the sabbath
i think that was the most interesting
one of all right yeah
and probably the most confused
i think there's a lot of people with the
same sentiment
same view now i think i'll stick to his
creation evolution lectures
because when it comes to this theology
there's quite a bit of confusion
number one the law was only given
to moses nobody before that kept the law
but even in the time of moses before he
got the law they kept the law
right there's scripture that supports it
and he has many arguments as to why is
not a seventh-day adventist and what the
law was
regarding the sabbath day and that it
was only given to the children of israel
now jesus came to correct
the false perceptions on the sabbath
the reasons why they went to go out and
collect
firewood to make fire on the sabbath
because the bible says
preparation day get your cooking and
things done
there's nothing wrong with warming up
your food or this or that or the other
but to go
collecting wood etc etc god was drilling
into them a sabbath
of rest in him
and it was a theocracy so when it came
to
sentences of death etc etc
that was under a theocratic system and
prefigured
an eternal death if you don't want to
find rest in him you will have eternal
death that's it if you're not satisfied
about how god treated the punishment
then
you won't be satisfied out of how he's
going to treat it
in the end exactly so under theocratic
laws
there were certain judicial laws as well
when israel chose a king then
the theocratic laws fell away but not
the ten commandments
they were forever so
let us just look at some of the laws and
things that he spoke about and see
if he is spot on or not so the law was
only given
to moses before that nobody kept the
sabbath
uh he completely forgets genesis chapter
which should be his forte as a
creationist
in genesis chapter 26 it tells us
because that abraham
obeyed my voice and kept my charge
my commandments my statutes and my laws
i wonder what laws abraham kept because
that was long before there was a jew
long before there was a moses so what
commandments did he keep
and if he did keep them why did he not
write them down
by the way how old
were the antediluvians how
old were the early post deluvians
how old were people in the time of
abraham
well they were over 900 years old in the
beginning yes
they were 400 years and older after the
flood and by the time you get to abraham
he was over 180 years old right
so these people were
brilliant their minds were
absolutely in a in contrast to
ours phenomenal
and most of them were living in a time
where his great great grandfather was
still probably alive
yes so everything was verbally still
everything was word of mouth
in fact the very descendants
of noah was still alive
in the time of abraham abraham still
communicated with them and spoke to them
so now they didn't have to write things
down
so only when the mind started to become
forgetful were these things codified
and language came into existence
so abraham kept the commandments the
statutes and the laws so they must have
existed before moses so
there's no way that kent hoven can be
right
on that score romans chapter 4 verse 3
says for what says the scripture abraham
believed god and it was accounted to him
for righteousness
so abraham kept the commandments and he
believed god
so the descendants of abraham
must keep the commandments and
believe god right did god say
remember the seventh sabbath there keep
it holy
yes know ye therefore that they which
are of faith the same are the children
of abraham so you must believe
and you must keep and the scripture was
fulfilled so it's james 2
23 which says abraham believed god
and it was imputed unto him for
righteousness and he was called the
friend of god
so now people say all right so all it
takes is to believe there's no
commandment
but they forget the verse genesis 26 5
here are they that keep the commandments
and have the faith of jesus
nothing has changed no nothing
nothing now here's a very interesting
portion of scripture this is now
before the children of israel left
egypt and you have this confrontation
with pharaoh
and the king of egypt said unto them
wherefore do you
moses and aaron let the people from
their works
get ye unto your burdens so obviously
moses and aaron were telling the people
don't work yes
now what irritated pharaoh
and pharaoh said behold the people of
the land
now are many and ye moses in other words
you make them rest when you look it up
the word is shabbat you moses
make the people keep the sabbath before
they left egypt
they'd obviously forgotten it doesn't
the commandments say remember
yes they'd forgotten so here comes moses
and aaron and they tell them you won't
work on the sabbath
and pharaoh lost it right yes
and he says why do you make them rest
from them and
get you to your burdens i will double
your workload
so that they can't finish it
by the friday they have to carry on them
so what law did pharaoh make there
wasn't
an anti-sabbath law correct aha
so if you read your bible carefully then
you can see that
none of these great preachers are
sticking to the biblical script
they're making their own script yes
tradition
and commandments of men yes
not of thus says the lord thus i think
and he has a wonderful book that i can
give you it's full of logic
but it's not full of the right scripture
why don't you bring the bible and say
okay let's study and see here yeah
because
i have a wonderful book it's called the
bible ah and like you've just shown
nehemiah which he quoted and the exodus
is quoted out of context
absolutely out of context and here's the
word that is
there you can look it up in the
strongest concordance
shabbat is rest keep the sabbath
that's what it said so what was god's
answer to pharaoh's anti-sabbath law
the blade plagues blood
frogs lice flies cattle boils
hail locusts darkness and the death of
the firstborn
now we've written some of them in blue
here
particular reason yes i'm sure because
it's going to have something to do with
the seven last ones
there are four plagues here which are
repeated
at the end of time four is the number of
the earth
north east south west so
what happened here in a local
application is going to happen
in a worldwide universal application
when an anti-sabbath law was made in the
time of the exodus which prefigured
the children of god or the children of
israel
spiritual israel going to canaan
there will be a repetition of four of
those plagues
in the last seven plagues and it's seven
plagues because that's the number of
completeness that's
god's number the number of god god's
wrath will be
complete and psalms 105
verse 43 to 45 tell us and he brought
forth
his people with joy and he's chosen with
gladness now they're going out of
egypt and gave them the lands of the
heathen
and they inherited the labor of the
people
so typically god's people are going to
inherit the earth
why that they might observe his statues
and keep its laws
so is it going to be in the in heaven
exactly the same
you won't be in heaven you won't be able
to go to heaven
if you refuse to keep god's commandments
and what a beautiful test the sabbath
day
yes remember the sabbath day
a lot of people say it's impossible to
keep the ten commandments but even paul
said the commandments is not a heavy
they're not burdensome no they're not
burdensome
so you're going to have to keep the
commandments because the bible says
that you will enter into heaven if you
keep the commandments
and jesus said it to to many
and he said how readeth thou what must i
do to inherit in turtle love how readeth
thou
keep the commandments if you love me
keep my commandments
absolutely exodus 16 4 then the lord
said to moses i will rain down
bread from heaven for you and the people
are to go
out each day and gather enough for that
day and this day i will test them
that i may prove them whether they will
walk in my law or not the sabbath became
a particular test
because the manner only
fell on a particular day six days you
shall gather it but on the seventh day
which
is the sabbath in it shall be none
not the monday the tuesday not your
sabbath there will be none
here's sabbath there will be none it's
so clear
exodus 16 29 see for that the lord has
given you the sabbath
therefore he giveth you on the sixth day
the bread
of two days abide ye every man in his
place let no man go out of his place on
the seventh day
now that's what he was talking about
right does that mean that you are
locked out now the jews made the law
and said you're allowed to walk a
thousand
meters on a on a sabbath day but that
was a jewish law
what he is saying is
don't go and explore the world we're
going to worship on this day
together worship god don't make big
plans
for moving around it doesn't say you're
locked in your room under lockdown
it's not a lockdown rule so they're
distorting the scriptures
now the most fascinating one
is the one where macarthur explains
why the sabbath is no longer binding
and i think it's very important that we
talk about what he has to say
because he's playing a very prominent
role in the days that we are living in
and we know from scripture that the
sabbath is going to be an important
issue now
i'm not saying these people are
deliberately vindictive
but as we've seen there are so many
different views
on the issue but they all seem to be
quite happy
to come together on the sunday right so
let's have a look
what macarthur has to say on the issue
how are we to understand the place that
the sabbath plays
if any in the life of
the people of god in six days the lord
made the heavens and the earth the sea
and all that is in them and rested on
the seventh day
therefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and made it holy
there is no question about the other
nine commandments being permanent
and binding those are all
moral mandates moral commands with the
exception of
verses 8 through 11 the fourth command
regarding the sabbath
and the question that is often posed
is a simple one if all the other
commands are permanent
is not this one permanent as well
there are people who believe it is and
we might call them
strict sabbatarians
they fall generally into two categories
one would be seventh day adventists
i think we're familiar with them
i think it's legitimate to consider
seventh-day adventism as a cult
because they believe that
the writings of ellen g white are
inspired by god
and can be put alongside the bible
but they identify themselves as
faithful to the fourth command
there are also seventh-day baptists a
smaller
group that interpret the commandment as
permanently binding as well
not quite so strict you could
also identify what you would call
christian sabbatarians
they have decided that
as christians we must keep the sabbath
but it's not any longer the seventh day
it's the first
day so they shift
the command in exodus from
saturday to sunday every um
every saturday america
the western world with its christian
influences
worked toward a five-day work week part
of that
was the underlying sense that
saturday was a day to enjoy the creation
saturday is a perpetual witness to god
as creator
sunday on the other hand is a perpetual
witness to god
as redeemer
jesus would never violate the ten
commandments jesus would never violate
the law of god
he is holy harmless undefiled separate
from sinners
but jesus did anything he wanted on the
sabbath
and incited the leaders in the doing of
it because it was part of bringing down
that whole
system in verse
17. he goes even beyond that
and defends what he did by saying this
my father is working
until now and i myself am working
wow this is a claim to be deity
my father and i are doing
our work before your eyes
we are working for this reason
therefore verse 18 the jews were seeking
all the more to kill him
because he not only was breaking the
sabbath but also was calling god his own
father making himself equal
with god
he was calling himself he was calling i
should say god his father
and continually involved in activities
that violated sabbath law
pharisees charged jesus breaking the
sabbath law making himself equal with
god
and this led them to kill him
eventually jesus never attempted to fit
his activities
into the sabbath law of the old covenant
he established his own authority
as one with god and as lord over the
sabbath
that was phenomenal
no indeed it was astounding
now i have great respect for
many things that this man has to say
i call seventh-day adventists a cult
definition of a cult is someone who has
an extraneous source
to the bible right
so the biggest cult on earth must be the
roman catholic church
because they have tradition and the
bible
and the bible has to be analyzed
and evaluated in the light of tradition
not the other way around
subservient so that's the biggest cult
the problem is of course
that their tradition is at variance with
the bible
it says exactly the opposite in most
cases
so there you have two sources
contradicting each other
which determine the doctrine and
therefore the bible
is set aside now seventh-day adventists
have the writings of ellen g white
but they are in absolute harmony with
the bible in fact they
are nothing but bible quotes and placing
them into context
so if somebody writes a book
which quotes bible verses and expands on
them
is that a cult isn't that what the
christian world does
so we could argue on that issue
then his fascinating statement that
jesus
broke the sabbath he says jesus never
broke any law
he was absolutely obedient but he broke
the sabbath law so jesus was intent on
bringing down the sabbath
did he yep so let's try and answer that
question
did jesus keep the sabbath
well let's go to the one verse which
says
that he did it according to his custom
luke chapter 4 verse 16 and 17
and he came to nazareth where he had
been brought up
and as his custom was he went into the
synagogue on the sabbath day and stood
up for to read
it was his custom to keep the sabbath
day
[Music]
and there was delivered unto him the
book of the prophet isaiah
and when he had opened the book he found
the place where it was written
and then he quotes this famous text and
says today the scripture is fulfilled
and now they've also got some people
that say yes
he did keep the sabbath but it was
because he was a jew and he had to keep
this
the laws of the jews we just now read
jesus's own verse do not think that i
have come to abolish
the law exactly not one jot or one
tittle
will by any means disappear from the law
is the sabbath commandment
written by the finger of god on tables
of stone
yes now macarthur said
that the others are logical laws
because they are definite injunctions
that you shall not steal you shall not
do but the sabbath
doesn't say that it says remember
therefore he discards it
with what right by whose authority
he's trying to say that jesus did it
himself
jesus did it himself all right
he even knocks the sunday yeah
but he keeps the sunday his church
services
are on a sunday well macarthur
is in court these days because of
violating the laws on the covet 19 for
not get churches are not allowed to get
together indoors on a sunday uh-huh so
in actual work
what you're saying is he is fighting for
sunday worship
while he himself says it's not important
now some people might say
yeah but that's only because they're
worshipping on sunday he is actually
just fighting for
worshipping but it's confusing
confusing but let's look what jesus did
as his custom was he went and kept the
sabbath
now people say the sabbath is not that
prominent in the new testament
the sabbath is incredibly prominent in
the new testament
and jesus came to fulfill the law
to put it in right settings he said to
the jews why do you
violate god's commandment for your
traditions
why do you have so many exactions
and rules and regulations which are not
part of the law of god
and there were 2 000 laws on how to keep
the sabbath
and the bible has a handful if i had to
go
and study the bible on exactly how to
keep the sabbath
and i study it then i will find that
god says do not neglect the assembly of
the saints
and god says call the sabbath a delight
not doing your own thing remember the
sabbath day
keep it honorable and then you run out
of injunctions
right so jesus came to put
the record straight yeah now his
miracles
his acts of benevolence his acts of
mercy
his acts of kindness they were
emphatically enacted
on the sabbath day and he would point
out the hypocrisy of the jews
shall not this woman think of it
this many years burdened with this
disease be set free on the sabbath day
which one of you having an
ox etc etc will not lead him to water or
if he's fallen
into a pit will not take him out on the
sabbath day
where are your thoughts did he break the
sabbath day or did he
elevate the scene elevated it according
to
his dictates so how can these people
even dare to say that jesus
broke the sabbath day they said
you weren't allowed to eat
or prepare food they were walking
through the field by the way today if i
go walking through someone's field
stealing his corn and eating it i would
be breaking the law right
i could would be trespassing it was a
law of god
that if you were traveling and you were
going through someone else's field
you were allowed to satisfy your
immediate need but you weren't allowed
to harvest and take
away for others or to sell there was
theft
so it was not breaking any law and
their laws of ritual washings weren't in
the bible
they had concocted them because they
wanted to
seem to be so rigid so the sabbath
is about love to god about
service to your neighbor and jesus came
to live out the essence of the law
and to say that he broke it is
almost a blasphemy almost a blasphemy if
it isn't
one because he was without sin and sin
is transgression of the law
i just want to ask um
kent ivan mentioned that
he has never met anybody that keeps the
sabbath because of
when you use electricity or water or any
of these
in god's original setup for the sabbath
this wouldn't have been a violation this
it wouldn't have been the same that we
have today no
today we are not under theocratic law
number one
and the law applies to those in whose
heart the law is written
so you and your household you will say i
will do
no unnecessary work but if i can
alleviate
a burden or help someone
not by cutting his lawn or fixing his
motor vehicle because i can do that on
any other day
but if that person is suffering i can go
and alleviate that suffering jesus did
that on the sabbath day
exactly and he is my example
so the sabbath to me is about worship it
is about
fellowship it's about being in community
communion with god and with his word
with his nature
and all of those things even jesus
when he was on earth even he went to
fellowship on a sabbath
he went to lazarus and mary and martha
correct
and what's interesting is
he attended the the synagogue on the
sabbath day
and thereafter went to peter's house on
one occasion
and peter's mother-in-law was sick
and he healed her on the sabbath day and
what did she do
she got up and ministered to them
provided a meal for them so that was all
lawful
on the sabbath day our denominational
name here's a quote from the spirit of
prophecy
i was shown in regard to the remnant
people of god taking a name
because these people all seem to have it
in for
the seventh-day adventists kendalvin
spoke about them
macarthur spoke about them they have a
problem with seventh-day adventists
exactly so
it's not that seventh the adventists are
unnoticed
no no they are noticed they are noticed
and they are irritating
to many people so i was shown in regard
to the remnant people of god taking a
name
two classes were presented before me one
class embraced the great bodies of
professed christians
they were trampling upon god's law and
bowing down to a papal institution
they say they don't keep it but they
keep it
they were keeping the first day of the
week as a sabbath
of the lord the other class who were but
few in number
were bowing to the great lawgiver they
were keeping the fourth commandment the
peculiar and prominent features of their
faith
where the observance of the seventh day
and waiting for the appearing of our
lord from heaven
that's the great hope of the christian
right
no name which we can take will be
appropriate but that which accords with
our profession
and expresses our faith and marks us as
a peculiar people
he spoke about the peculiar people and
he said
that only the jews were peculiar people
and that's why they had peculiar laws
that's why they had peculiar laws but
peter addressing the christian
church says you are a peculiar people a
holy priesthood
a special treasure the name seventh-day
adventist is a standing rebuke to the
protestant world
that's why they have to call it a cult a
sect
well so was paul called
a sec yes and he said by what you call a
sect
i am happy to be part of it exactly here
is the line of distinction between the
worshipers of god
and those who worship the beast and
receive his mock
it's interesting how they they tread
water this way that way
but they ignore the direct teaching of
the word of god
the great conflict is between the
commandments of god and the requirements
of the beast
even amongst god's people that was jesus
great conflict
in how to obey god yes
it is because the saints are keeping all
ten of the commandments that the dragon
makes war upon them
if they will lower the standard and
yield the peculiarities of their faith
the dragon will be at peace but the
excite is ire
because they have dared to raise the
standard and
unfurl their banner in opposition to the
protestant world
who are worshiping the institution of
the papacy
and they all have their own reasons yes
there's different reasons for why
they're keeping the sunday
and they are pointing out the seventh
adventists
as the culprits that's the problem the
name seventh-day
adventist carries the true features of
our faith
in front and will convict the inquiring
mind
like an arrow from the lord's quiver it
will wound the transgressors of god's
law and will lead to repentance towards
god and
faith in our lord jesus christ
do these people think that
people like you and i one day decided
i would like to be part of a cult
maybe i can join a sec that does
something weird like keep the sabbath
and destroy my career and destroy my
friendships
and destroy everything that that makes
life
exciting on this continually um
yeah do they think that
or is there a compelling reason
why we have become seventh
day adventists
i was shown that almost every fanatic
who has arisen
who wishes to hide his sentiments that
he may lead away others claims to belong
to the church of god
such a name would at once excite
suspicion for it
is employed to conceal the most absurd
errors
this name is too indefinite for the
remnant people of god it would lead to
the supposition that we had a faith
which we wish to cover up
we are seventh-day adventists are we
ashamed of our name
we answer no no we are not
it is the name the lord has given us it
points out the truth
that is to be the test of the churches
we are seventh day adventists and of
this name we are never to be ashamed
as a people we must take a firm stand
for truth and righteousness
thus we shall glorify god we are to be
delivered from the dangers
not ensnared and corrupted by them
that this may be we must look ever to
jesus the author and finisher of
our faith and he kept the sabbath he
made the sabbath holy
he was merciful kind and
showed the power of his deity on the
sabbath day
he is lord of the sabbath i'll follow
his example
and even the example of his disciples
correct
which kept the sabbath fall right
through
he didn't change in the end now all of
these protestant denominations
know full well that the bible says
saturday is the sabbath
they all know it yes and yet they
violate it
and they say don't come with cultish
ideas to me
i will decide when the sabbath is but
it's not for us to decide it's already
been decided
by god yes now let's listen
to what the ultimate usurper of god's
word
has to say on this issue
let's listen to pope francis
he obviously knows that the jews are
keeping the right day
now was he propagating for keeping the
sabbath we will have to check that out
right
it's obvious that they changed the day
because
the babysit claims that the pope has
power to change
times to abrogate laws and to dispense
with all things
even the precepts of christ what an
arrogant statement
which is the sabbath day saturday is the
sabbath day
why do we observe sunday instead of
saturday we observe sunday instead of
saturday because the catholic church
transferred
the solemnity from the saturday to the
sunday
that's the converts catechism of
catholic doctrine
so they're telling you they changed it
so the christian world is keeping a
child of the papacy
and here is laudato si
the famous encyclical which i understand
will be
augmented as the pope speaks
at the united nations we must talk about
that next time
on sunday our participation in the
eucharist has
special importance sunday like the
jewish sabbath
is meant to be a day which heals our
relationship with god with ourselves and
with
others and with the world
the law of weekly rest forbade work on
the seventh day so that your
ox and your donkey may have rest
now why is he keeping the first day
here's another statement from the book
maranata
just want to say so what we've seen now
is how the protestant denominations
see sunday and we've seen clearly how
the purpose of the papers he sees
absolutely and it's in harmony
absolutely so what they have got in
common
they have in common a day which is not
sanctified
by the word of god and they have in
common
that they are in opposition to the word
of god
the papacy is the only one that is
absolutely clear
the bible says so we changed it
we are above the bible we can change
even the precepts of christ we are god
on earth they they blunt on it they're
blunt
no and the others they've actually
they're saying the same you know what if
you say that
because of the tradition that it's been
changed
and all of these other excuses
is actually in harmony with what the
papacy says yes because they don't have
it thus says the word they must have a
thousand excuses
in fact they are inventing excuses
to excuse the papacy yes
they're inventing them to excuse the
beast
when the protestants the early
protestants
paid with their lives to expose it
there is no protestantism anymore
the only consistent protestants
are the seventh-day adventists not
because i'm one no
it's not because we're boasting or it's
being
smart is because that is the only one
that is
keeping to the commandments of god
correct
i was raised catholic my mother was
protestant
the most logical thing for me is to
choose one of those two
i'm neither i'm neither why because
the bible convinced me that there is
only one choice if you want to be in
harmony with the bible in fact you know
what
the roman catholic church has
categorically stated that if you want to
believe the bible you should be a
seventh-day adventist they said it yes
we actually didn't put it up but that's
important because
the roman catholic church and all these
ones that we've seen now
acknowledges seventh-day adventists does
that make me great does that make you
great
no we are sinners saved by grace just
like kent oven said
yes but we've made a choice keep the
commandments of god
and show the world that you
believe god keep the seventh day can you
be an
evolutionist and remember the sabbath
day
that god made the world in six days no
no
i was an evolutionist do you think it
was
easy for me to change from an
evolutionist to
becoming a creationist definitely not no
my colleagues
loved it or roared with laughter lord
rord one of my colleagues said the man
was struck by lightning they even spit
in your face
they even spat on my face yes so this is
a choice
this is a choice that you have to make
doesn't make me great it just makes the
bible great
and jesus confronted hypocrisy and so
the seventh-day adventist the true
seventh-day adventists don't think that
every seventh-day
adventist is the bee's knees in this
world we
all fall short of the glory of god we're
no better than anyone
else in this world but we have
recognized
that the word of god is authoritative
even
to the point of telling us where we have
to be obedient
i just want to also say and with all
this
that we've now seen on these dominant
denominations
and the religion part we've dealt with
the
political part where um they all want to
bring
this guard back into the
politics so church and state and which
day
are they promoting sunday the whole time
all the time
evil and evil says the lord the eternal
it is coming the hour has come the hour
is striking
and it's striking at you the hour and
the
end this is the quote from ezekiel 7 5
and 6.
fearful is the issue to which the world
is to be brought the powers of earth
uniting to war
against the commandments of god as you
said
the secular world the religious world
the earth lovers the gaia people they're
all on the bandwagon
they will decree that all both small and
great rich and poor
free and bond shall conform to the
customs of the church by observance of
the false sabbath
all who refuse compliance will be
visited with civil penalties and will
finally be declared that they
are deserving of death you can see the
animosity
don't send me anything more i don't want
to hear from you seventh-day adventists
you are a cult
whatever words they want to say then
jesus was a
part of a cult then the disciples were
part of the cult
did the disciples keep the sabbath yes
did they keep the ten commandments
did they ever teach that the law was
abrogated that it was gone
no no so what are they
they must be and if they were alive
today
they would be seventh-day adventists
they wouldn't have a choice right
on the other hand the law of god and
joining the creator's rest day demands
obedience and threatens wrath against
all who transgress its precepts
with the issue thus clearly brought
before him whosoever shall trample upon
god's law to obey a human enactment
receives the mark of the beast
and the beast has clearly said it
he accepts the sign of allegiance to the
power which he chooses to obey
instead of god and that's why the bible
in revelation 12 17 says the dragon was
wrath with the woman the church and went
make war against the remnant of our seed
which keep the commandments of god
which includes the sabbath and have the
testimony of jesus
our people have been regarded as too
insignificant to be worthy of notice
but a change will come the christian
world is now making movements which will
necessarily bring commandment keeping
people into prominence
the whole world is to be stirred with
enmity against
seventh-day adventists because they will
not
yield homage to the papacy by honoring
sunday the institution of this
anti-christian power it is the purpose
of satan
to cause them to be blotted from the
earth in order that his supremacy of the
world
may not be disputed we don't have to
read
the rest that is enough now we're seeing
this
absolutely the animosity is increasing
because the line of demarcation
is clearly drawn in the sand
this is the line this is the choice
now brothers out there and sisters
why would you want to make a choice that
is not based on the word of god
why would you want to even consider it
why take that risk
matthew 10 22 says you will be hated of
all men for my name's sake
but he that endureth to the end shall be
saved
there is no necessity for thinking that
we cannot endure persecution we shall
have to go through terrible times
the persecution of protestants by
romanism
by which the religion of jesus christ
was almost annihilated will be
more than rivaled when protestantism and
purpory are combined
can you see it happening in the world
yes
there will be a union of opposing
elements against them
forever diverse from each other
different
organizations may be in their sentiments
and religious
faith their forces are united in
trampling underfoot the fourth
commandment
and the law of god those who will not
themselves accept the truth are
most zealous that others shall not
receive it
do we see that we see it very prominent
and no matter how diverse they're
thinking on the issue
they are all on the same page when it
comes to this
you mentioned the united nations and we
will see
because we showed in the pre in previous
episodes
the world economic forum the united
nations
what is everybody what
is bringing them together the same thing
the sunday the sunday
so there will be persecution all that
will live godly in christ jesus
shall suffer persecution second timothy
12 those who live during the last days
of this earth's history will know what
it means to be persecuted for the
truth's sake
in the courts injustice will prevail the
judges will refuse to listen
to the reasons of those who are loyal to
the commandments of god
because they know that the arguments in
favor of the fourth commandment
are unanswerable they will say
we have a law and by our law he ought to
die
god's law is nothing to them our law
with them is supreme did rick warren
says he has a sabbath
did the other one say it doesn't matter
which day it is
did god specify a day yes
i just want to say this whole
discussion has brought forth the sabbath
and the reason being this is going to
play a very prominent role in the end
absolutely and we have shown quite
extensively
how it is a prominent role and from here
on
now we can also start in the next
episodes
discussing the united nations but also
the persecution the seven lost plagues
and then there's also the final
restoration i can't wait for that amen
those who respect this human law will be
favored but those who will not bow down
to the idle sabbath
will have no favor shown them
if this is false prophecy
then history hasn't taken place and we
are not in existence
correct because these things are
happening right before our eyes we can
see it
every single day may god give
everybody out there wisdom
it's not rocket science
keep the commandments of god so that you
may have
access to the tree of life it's as
simple as that
jesus never came to abolish the law he
came to fulfill it
and don't use false arguments to make
him
a law breaker while stating that he
never broke the law
out of the same breath in the same
sentence
may god give us wisdom to keep the
commandments of god
hold to the testimony and we will see
each other on the sea of glass
may god bless you let's pray
heavenly father the issue
has so clearly been brought before us
the choice is such a simple one who has
authority in our lives
may people make a choice lord that the
only source
source of authority in the entire
universe
that has eternal consequences
is the choice for thus says the lord
give us the strength to follow a thus
says the lord in jesus name amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you